hello out there welcome into the BR 2019
NBA draft show I'm Taylor rooks here
with a lovely cats of characters we've
got Josh Hart and we have Tobias Harris
who Josh Hart says looks like tickle
Jake hole not gonna lie you kind of do
like him too if we're being honest I've
heard that too you talk like well we
have free agent Tobias Harrison I
actually think this is your first
appearance as a pelican how you feeling
I'm feeling good I'm excited you're here
I mean we got a lot of picks a lot of
picks so we got some good guys coming I
don't know we're gonna take a number one
but we're gonna find out ya know I do
have a very quick question for you
before we kind of go all around to the
many different people that we have
joining the show today
you posted a smiley face on your
Instagram story once you once you got
traded yeah I would just like to go into
the mind of Josh I don't know I guess
just new beginning I think that's what
it is
obviously I love being a Laker in my
time there was an amazing time there I'm
thankful for the organization for you
know just a fresh start you know get to
build something new from the ground up
and that kind of things that kind of
that's kind of where that came from
you buy in that device I'm buying that
cuz it's been there before yeah a couple
of times matter of fact so I know when
you get traded it's a new like a new
beginning for you where you can go over
to new organization start yourself out
the way you want
he's pretty established in the league
already with what he's done so it's a
new start for him with a young talented
team so I could I could see how why he
was excited for that one hi Jake old now
there's a whole bunch of players tonight
that are gonna have new beginnings new
starts and we're tracking it all we have
people everywhere
starting in Vegas where we're gonna be
looking at all the odds that are
updating with the sports book so let's
head out and see what Kelly's doing in
Vegas thanks Taylor we're down here at
the Caesars Palace sports book all night
for the draft the oddsmakers here have
set up some awesome front mats for all
of these fans behind me to bet on but
one thing they didn't do was set the
over-under on how many Lakers fans were
gonna be here the answer is way too many
no joking but I do like Carson Edwards
tonight as my favorite prop but I do
believe he's gonna get dropped in the
first round so yes - 125 is my favorite
bet what do you think
I mean hey listen I'm a Carson Edwards
fan I covered here when I was at the Big
Ten Network and he was playing at Purdue
he's undersized but he has a bit of like
the Fred vanvleet in them so I'm gonna
take your bed I'm gonna take your bed
all right I like it
all right do you guys know anything
about Big Ten basketball where it's at
Big Ten bad smells better than SEC
baskerville you do know that ACC is
better than Big Ten but not as easy at
one point those days are long gone but
shout out Villanova like y'all whine you
got it done it's fine all right we have
some fans at Barclays that are also
incredibly excited for their teams to
make some big moves so let's head out
it's Brooklyn and check in on the fan
reactions for this your local DMV native
right here looking forward to you being
on the Pelican
wait for you to ball was I on throwing
them the alley-oop
hit the three spot he said the dunks on
everybody Tobias Harris when you join in
the 76ers they may not doubt it let's go
pelicans don't let's go that's a very
question when you join them we can be
roommates broke like I live alone but
New Orleans oh that is such a fun city
you have to be incredibly excited to be
going there Josh we recruited you're
just open I know you were fielding some
kind of you wanted some New Orleans
opinions you put out a tweet I had a bit
of a problem
mm-hmm you asked who has the best
beignets yeah that is an incredibly
obvious question you do know that right
no see okay this is why so um I went to
school in Philly yeah so everyone else
so obviously Philly's big for
cheesesteaks so everyone's like oh
pastor Geno's because they get the most
publicity they get you know the most
love what path and Geno's aren't the
best cheesesteaks if you go to like
South Street you hit up like it's
Gibble's or Jim I say it's good but it's
good bevels gyms they're better than
passing Geno's so all the I obviously
I've been a cafe du monde I had there
been gays I wanted to know like I is
that the best beignet spot there or is
that the one that gets the most
publicity so you know I had it and so
what was the consensus Cafe Du Monde
okay yeah have you had before yeah well
in honor of our newest New Orleans
Pelican
we brought you some baby gays oh yeah
yeah it's we just got a chomp on em I'll
show ya I'm all in it yes this is your
welcome to New Orleans
you wanna die I'll do it for me
and maybe being in New Orleans that's
[Music]
good messed up just motor it's fine do
whatever you need to do beignets are
supposed to be messy and the draft has
kind of been messy so far we've got a
lot of trades happening your team is
definitely winning right now you're
gonna have the number one pick number
eight 1735 David Griffin killing it I
think we all agree number one is going
to be okay and you know what you guys
are right the first pick is in and it is
I on Williamson you have a new team to
take a drink to that
when you think about playing Briana what
comes to mind Josh um I was in his
explosiveness I think that's the biggest
thing um I think his strength I'd be a
big thing obviously he's a super
talented kid obviously want to see you
know we're definitely gonna get him in
there working on his jump shot a little
bit make sure that Jimmy's right but you
know just tremendous upside I'm a I'm
excited he's a publican and you know big
things coming
you know it's wise I think right now the
thing with Zion is a lot of hype is
around him you and it is hard to live up
to a lot of hype mm-hmm
is he going to do that I think you will
I think you know obviously everybody
knew this pic was coming right but at
dinner they don't the way he carries
himself you know I'm really impressed
with that he's no first-class type of
guy and people always want to know like
how good is how good is he gonna be our
top B of all time I was like he's
already walking into average of 10
points cuz ain't nobody gonna be trying
to get dunked on by him so that's the
easy 10 for him right away so you know
and his gang will continue to progress
but he's he's the number one pick for
short got the most hyping I think he's
ready you know the thing that's funny
about Zion I met him at the Final Four
and obviously he's this big guy this
talented guy but he's very much so a kid
uh-huh have you guys ever met him no I
heard you know like he's kind of big and
awkward and goofy and figuring it out
and there's that transition that
you know from being this freshman phenom
to going to the NBA
so what's that transition like just
having to grow up really fast I mean
when you get into the week I was 18 when
I got over will you come in 18 years old
but I think you know we all forget how
young he is because of how good he is
but he's gonna continue to develop like
on and off the floor but I'll say you
know even as I touched on before he
carries himself in a real good way that
you can just tell he's humble he's been
well groomed by parents and whatnot so I
feel like just for him coming in having
good people around him like my man right
here that's gonna be able to show him
the ropes teach them see him in the gym
and with all the pics they're getting
they got a young core so you know he's
going to be he's in good hands
regardless yeah and I think everybody
kind of saw how talented Zion was from
beginning we have some clips of him in
high school and you could always see
that explosiveness he was running over
everybody already who's already the most
athletic person on the court it's easy
to be the most athletic person on the
court in high school and in college he's
not gonna be the most athletic person on
the court in the NBA you know maybe like
you put him on the bra you could yeah
then I think LeBron I'm like you're
knocking the most I think person ever do
you say LeBron who else do you think
rival Zion right there Aaron Gordon yeah
let it doesn't yeah I mean I'm in terms
of just size and explosion you're saying
there is only one more person in the NBA
that's gonna be more athletic than Zion
Williams in I mean that's fine if that's
what you're saying but let's what I'm
saying this was somebody at his age
coming in to be that athletic you're not
you're not seeing anybody else like at
that level where I don't f lettuce ISM
to be how much he weighs to jump like
that and to run
noth-nothing anything like that okay so
like we're saying that now you know I
actually saw today he said he wasn't
interested in the dunk contest do you
think he really is gonna stick to that
depends without uh I don't blame the VRS
why well the Duncans has been kind of
weak lately hey go for it would be nice
if he wasn't a doc on touch if I was him
I wouldn't do it left I left that uh
that championship-winning at a dunk
contest there's a nice little bonus I'll
do it so when was the last time dunk
contest was good Aaron Gordon and that
gave us like all the expectations you
just want to be that good it wasn't so
now we just we're spoiled come yeah so
how do you approach good it's actually
really cool that we have someone who's
going to be a teammate of the number one
pick first thing you say to Zion is
going to be just welcome to the league
um I think that the the biggest thing I
guess for him was just trying to show
him I mean obviously I'm just a second
you know going into my third year but
just trying to show him as much as I as
I know um because like you said you know
it's different in college things move a
lot faster but that's the perk that he's
18 years old or 19 years or whatever he
is
so he gets to learn early and kind of
you know he's not setting his ways you
know whether you know I was a four-year
guy so I was kind of more so set on my
way sided kind of reach aims everything
for him you know is more precious more
new so just woke them and you know kind
of like let's get started do have you
guys seen Zions outfit we have a picture
of Zion yeah Roby wore to the draft you
liked it you did it it's interesting
choice it's his face says it all I think
he's clean I mean like it uh it
resembles kind of LeBron suit yeah yeah
so I can see where he may have been
going with that so I give them again a
for creativity
however he was saying his stylist said
that the white was gonna look really
good on his skin and that's why he
decided to go with that but I'm sure
some of it was a little bit of a new
style said that yes Cyrus I did an
interview second pick is in JAMA Rancho
which I think that we all saw coming
mm-hmm yeah we big drummer and fans yeah
I am oh yeah I think they'll be good
what do you like about him me I like his
his ability to play make and really
attack I mean he's a he's a guard and
everybody wants guards and ladies
explosive khan reminds me like Damien
literally went to a small school coming
up now so I feel like he plays with a
chip on his shoulder he's ready every
single night to shoot the three-ball so
I think he's one of the most ready
guards in this whole draft yeah I think
for me I think definitely the ability to
play makers is the biggest thing and be
able to get your good teammates of all
obviously he went to a small school but
you know he carried that team he made
his teammates better I think that's you
know wanted you know your biggest job as
a point guard obviously you know his
ability to just score and his explosion
is amazing amazing ability to make his
teammates better well I think is gonna
make it separate him from a lot out of
point guard yeah so I had John morant on
my show take it there and I actually
talked to him about that transition from
college to the NBA and what that was
going to be like the challenges that
will come at that and he had a lot to
say let's see it what goals do you have
at IMG Academy when you think about
playing in the NBA things you know you
have to get better at for you to succeed
I thought level I say the biggest is
probably of getting stronger the
physicality in the NBA is different than
college you have way bigger guys I would
switch being stronger being able to
finish through contact and also a public
conditioning obviously I'll probably be
playing 50-plus more games and I did in
college so just to be in the best shape
I can be for those 82 games do you have
any concerns about just going to the NBA
like I know for rookies they have the
rookie transitional program
because your life changes so much
there's anything making nervous about
becoming a star I was out nervous about
it obviously like coming from under the
radar I'm not used to all the
recognition and stuff that's something
I'm still getting used to that's
probably be the only thing just model
recognition other than that I think I'll
be fine so he said he needed to get
stronger when you look at him now he
actually does look really small how is
he gonna be able to do that in the NBA
what's the key to getting stronger and
being able to be sustainable in the leaf
being consistent you know with you know
working out which strength coach but
also eating eating right I think that's
the biggest thing I think that's one of
the thing that's really overlooked is
this you know your eating habits
something that's probably he does that
those two things I think he can
definitely put some weight off good suit
that's a good suit his pocket square I
saw was uh was like a was a photo of him
right that's why I saw it I saw so I
know he has trained to go stitched in
the arm and beneath no one stitch in the
back which is like I guess those are two
things some and his daddy used to say so
he's incorporating his dad into the suit
all that good stuff so he's going to
Memphis honestly do we care about the
Grizzlies seriously do we care about the
Grizzlies and it's joggling to make us
care about the Grizzlies I think is
omegas clear bottom I mean they just
right now they traded Mike Conley away
yeah so this was the opening up footage
on rent to come in run the show
you know they got Jackson on the team to
is another young talent I had a great
great rookie year too so I mean yeah
up-and-coming team they got away from
the grit the green grind team they all
those guys are out now so it's another
it's another group of young players
coming up so you know I mean I like John
Mayer a whole lot as a point
so I think he's gonna make that seam go
so I you know I'd be excited to see what
they can do that is so much the piranha
rookie though you're gonna have to come
in for sure team which we don't care
about right now and you're tasked you
know it's true you keep laughing every
time I say it doesn't mean they're bad
just means there's teams that you care
about more than other teams that's just
the media yeah that's what sells that's
what gets the clicks do you care about
the crazies I'm genuinely asking I care
about any NBA team this is the business
so I gotta care about everything I care
about my team team I'm going almost over
everybody but I don't think anybody look
like about that's for the media and the
fans yeah so good for them mm-hmm
personal he's gonna revitalize them but
how hard is that gonna be to go in there
as a rookie and have to do that it's a
that's a lot to put on someone that's
tough definitely struggle but I mean I
think putting the right pieces in place
I think you'd definitely be able to
learn I think the biggest thing is I
think Tobias talked on and did learn
from experience and I think he'd be able
to like he liked the buyer said run the
show I kind of learned that way though I
think he's gonna be amazing his first
year I don't I don't know I him he could
be but you know I think obviously
there's a you know transition but I mean
I think it would be good I think you got
to get a lot of excitement back into
that city and you know into that team
yes and make me be like I care about the
Grizzlies so much third pick is in the
Knicks elect RJ Barrett know which we
all knew he only wanted to go to New
York which I thought was really really
nice all he was talking about was how
badly he wanted to play in the city New
York is a lot though I know that's a
thing that said anytime someone comes
here
what is the talk in the league about
playing in New York and why is it such a
big deal well New York is the mecca you
know the garden as a as a special place
to place so you know obviously a lot of
people knew RJ Barrett was was there it
was their favorite pic here but you know
fans media
New York you lates him but he's going to
a situation where it's a young team that
he can come in and make his impact on
and just show his skills I mean this guy
right here is he's got a big frame good
good skills shoot the ball can get
downhill I mean you know so they're
looking for him to come in and be ready
to go yes already
newbies turned into the new the new one
and - no for real though they are it was
like a couple of years ago was like you
know only Kentucky is the one in dumb
place but Duke is now kind of taking
that on I would agree with that because
they got RJ but okay
when you look at it who do you think
will have the best NBA career out of the
Duke players do you still say Zion yeah
there is an argument for RJ pusher you
know like if that's the thing I think
Knicks fans were really let down that
they weren't going to get Zion but RJ
actually fits really well with New York
and they need a player like RJ so I
think it could all work out but
obviously with a lot of these new
players that means new potential Rookie
of the Year Award winners so for seeing
how those odds are shuffling out let's
go back to Kelly and Vegas
[Music]
[Applause]
now listen obviously the first round of
the draft is going as expected so let's
touch on those three players as far as
Rookie of the Year is concerned kay Zion
we know is the frontrunner favorite at
three to one here John Moran not far
behind reductions some money coming on
JA but to put it all in perspective to
you guys let's look at next year's MVP
odds my boy Jana is sitting at the top
at three to one
but Zion if you bet $100 on them you're
gonna get back five thousand dollars so
just a little bit of perspective for you
guys one of the cool things that we get
to do here at the be are betting studio
at Caesar's Palace if get to get behind
the counter and talk to some of the odds
makers these guys put up twenty twenty
points per game for the first three
rookies drafted and surprisingly Zion is
not the front-runner
RJ Barrett John Moran sitting there as
the two favorites Taylor what do you
think of those two bets I'm actually
going to agree with the Vegas I think
that John Moran will probably gets most
points for a game out of those three
rookies just because he's gonna have
such a heavy load of placing my commie
leading that team so I agree with that
Kelly awesome Taylor it's made you an
honorary book maker here in Las Vegas
alright you guys I put my money where my
mouth is I make some bets okay fourth
pick is in and the Hogs my city we
select DeAndre hunter did you put
DeAndre hunter on your mom draft yeah
did you I didn't put him down but I did
mine before the Hawks got that pick true
who cheated I'm in Chino you had an
advantage though yeah okay Hawks DeAndre
hunter obviously big difference of
minded guy how do you think he'll fit in
Atlanta gonna be good
nothing could be you know he'll be a
good win that they need I said I got
Trey you got a tray you got a good young
with him if you got Amari Spellman you
have can we hurt our heater and I'm not
shy to say it last night but he would be
another one to that young core some
who's complaining make a little bit but
some who definitely came from we're
doing good defensive minded
I think it'd be good yeah I like his
game I mean he can play like either
three four three four spot and they're a
young team they like to get up and down
space the floor let Trey on getting pick
and rolls and he's gonna find a spot
there so the thing about the Hawks is
they got a lot of versatile players so
he'd be able to come in and just play
different positions learn and grow but
he has a good skill set for for that
type of team so that's a good fit for
them for sure and that's why they moved
up to get it - yeah but how good can the
Hawks be I think I think chuckle well we
had lost to them this year we had lost
and I remember we did come back in a
locker I'm like Danny like they're good
like you know cuz after all-star break
they had like a really good record - was
in every single game so I feel like the
Hawks team they got young talent great
coach
they got young guys I want to get up and
down and just play and they got a point
guard I can shoot the ball and get down
hill and create play so I think they're
gonna be good
I do you know every time Tobias talks
and like where does he want to go he's
talking good about this what is he
trying to be in Atlanta I mean come on I
mean we're good okay they're good - you
talk about a good time like what how did
that game though how badly did you lose
so so the first game we barely won we
won by a couple and it was a high
scoring high scoring game and then I
remember I was out kinda my knee issues
so they went down to a land of right
before it was like the first game or the
last game before all-star break and I
think they lost by like well not we they
lost cuz I know that's not a team that's
weak I don't play dough
Oh
that's publican now so de los I think
was that good I think was like a
10-point game at least I think I think
about the double I want to say it was a
double-digit game today guys know they
got some good young guys good young core
um and they're competitive and they're
young and they got a lot they all got a
lot of proof so they play all out you
know the whole game yeah what are the
best NBA cities do you put it land out
there
mmm who do you put there well in terms
of fan base or in terms like living
having to live there oh I just think
it's funny i he just he said no and this
it yeah yeah we're we're Falcons like I
think about the fence much more than a
camera the Hawks I would be really
honest to doing that I go to fact these
games I've maybe been to two Hawks games
but Atlanta's not one of the best cities
to live in put it like this like out of
30s and it's in like the 1010 okay so
what's one la la I mean la is a great
city you could put the LA both LA teams
Toronto Miami's a good city Chicago just
casually in Miami yeah you guys
listening to this these are the cities
that New Orleans is amazing I heard no
one is it no one is an amazing city you
have the best city but this is my thing
where cities is like where you're
playing a lot of things affected so you
could be in a good city but you may not
have great fan base
yes that's like dang but you could be in
like okay City but your fans is off the
chain like okay I love coming to work
you know what I mean okay singing like
Utah poor yeah okay cities but they're
family fans is crazy
yeah okay so then what are the cities
that I've heard it's me Sacramento you
do not want to go there and you do not
want to go to Cleveland
[Laughter]
I used to live it's not the team I'm
okay well I will say the consensus from
what I have heard about MBC cities don't
go to Sacramento and don't go to
Cleveland but people actually enjoy Utah
it's pretty the fans are great it's
chill it matches a lot of people's like
personalities OKC is not bad but
everything closes it like seven o'clock
that's true
so that is terrible you can't eat
anything past 7:00 and that kind of
sucks
speaking of Cleveland the fifth pick is
in the Cavs have selected
Darius Garland did anyone have him I had
no I have that today you had Darius 5:5
right now my fingers already call a
sexist so I was like they probably not
going to go with another point guard but
this kid is this kid is good like really
good I mean he can shoot he can shoot
the ball obviously coming off the injury
but you know he showed everybody even
through the workouts and playing that
he's a elite shooter on the next level
so I mean I could see them parent both
them together but I didn't expect this
this pick for them though yeah I mean
the thing is obviously he got hurt yeah
but before job Marant exploded Darius
garland was the guy that was who we
thought we would be talking about all
the time but I've seen I heard it hurt
him a little bit but this is good I mean
yeah see tore his meniscus and November
yeah I saw this fax I thought that was
interesting that his favorite NBA
players Bradley Beal Bradley's great but
that's just not who you usually hear
yeah you know when you hear a player
does he remind you Bradley Beal yeah
that's my girly but he picked it yeah
well maybe cuz he's you know better bo
can shoot the ball yeah yeah you know
those kids who could really the shooter
too but I mean I think this draft has
probably like three really good elite
point guards and and maybe four you know
I like
kid from North Carolina Toby I like him
a lot
and the other two right here so I think
that you're gonna see in this draft
three point guards that are going to be
in situations where they can play and
grow and you're gonna see like point
guards for the next these three blossom
into their games in the next you know 10
years yeah I will say I think Darius at
least for me might win best outfit did
you guys see it do we have a picture of
what Darius were to the draft because
it's very good I know who wore worse
outfit they're gonna find a way know who
know i'ma see if he's in a lottery and
we're gonna talk about we're gonna see I
don't know I think it is but we'll see
they're fighting Darius is outfit but
he's wearing like I don't want to call
it a kimono but it's long he didn't go
that your dish okay yeah yeah I saw his
it looks really interesting this is uh
this is we're not looking at xerius
we're looking at Volvo oh yeah that
ain't nice you like it oh no okay I just
did my thing since fashion is going into
the trends of okay what the person likes
I just need to know where's the
inspiration for okay there could be a
background for that's a tie
that's dope because creativity Trump's
all that so I need to hear it back last
we'll see the thing that's interesting I
was watching some of his interviews
someone asked him about spiders and they
said what do you do and you like see a
spider he said he was scared of spiders
look wait a minute so why'd he have a
spider web yes oh yeah right if used to
tell me that when he see spiders like he
picks them up play scared us a little
different yes we do up Tereus Garland's
outfit come on that's clean okay I would
say it's
it's interesting kind of looks like a
Jedi what I must say is i like going
against the north clear I wear suits
right so next year we're gonna see
somebody walk up there with a team team
sweat suit on so that's the trend we
going now that's what we if you go
change it up now then we go keep seeing
a different trend two-minute pause
rewind I know that we might not have
this but let's look for it I need to
know what you wore because you even
critique my my own okay so you know
somebody made my suit and then after it
you know I got driving in 2011 so you
know three buddies you've got in so now
three buds is not it hmm so that's where
mine was that so so looking back I was a
badass girl once
sounds like five and a half I'll give
you but at the time was probably was was
cool I mean if fashion always changes so
it's like you can have something that
was dope at the time but then like
looking back it's like why do I wear
that like at the time that's what it was
like that's what was cool so and tailors
weren't that big at a time you could do
we look huge
alright okay but listen but hey I didn't
know I was going to Charlotte and my
suit matched my hat though
another peep that a my time I'll do the
bed not a bad like I said like I said
tailors weren't really in at that time
how did you feel it's not as bad as you
think though you went
thing is you went classic as far as the
color yeah so even here's um you're
never gonna get cloud like LeBron do you
way worse whoever drew good drew good
draft day so is the worst suit ever
worse than Jackie Manoa haze was bad you
know we got to bring up Julie yeah we
this is the worst one ever
what do you wear oh man what like any
I'm really put into words you just know
with you and I tell you this suit is
tailors were non-existent
at that time no there was no such thing
as a tailor yeah what was it like you
know someone who was like wanting to go
to the league you were ready but you
weren't in the green room like what was
that like for you um it was just nervous
I was nervous I was anxious just because
I had no idea where I would go
I think like the earliest I thought I
might go would be 21 to OKC and then I
knew probably the latest I would go
would be 32 to Phoenix so but it was I
mean I guess it like that was I tweeted
today I was like that was like the
longest day of my life too because I had
no idea what where all that ago I didn't
know if I would be a first time picker
there be a second I'll pick those is
somewhat uncertainty so I was nervous I
was looking good for like up to like
pick 17 oh that's atrocious this is my
man this is no okay
honestly though it isn't good but you
remember when Obama wore that tan Easter
suit it was clean it was that color it
reminds me of that it just doesn't look
as good but the colors look really good
with the hat and the basketball I'm
looking at the bright side okay yeah you
it's not great but it isn't terrible but
okay you were saying you were nervous
until yeah I was in there I was I wasn't
really nervous until like 17 to 18 pic
and I was just like I have no idea where
I'm going and that's where I was just
kinda like I
that's what didn't ever start really
coming in it's crazy though cuz you
probably you think of somebody like Zion
we all know he's going number one he
probably knows he's going number one but
you still have nerves like where do
those nerves come from no you knew you
were gonna get drafted higher you know
you're gonna be first round so what is
it exactly you're nervous about does
that make sense just just a moment I
think yeah you know I've said I wasn't
no one pic but I can just tell with with
puppies on just a moment okay listen his
hair but you still you know you never
know what could happen yeah I know for
me I was 19 pick but after picks out the
lottery every pick was like dang I mean
you dropped one more like you looking up
like now I encoded those three teams to
work out so they may not drive me either
so you're like really trying to
contemplate where you you're fit is that
or where you gonna be drafted that so
you know it's a I said nerve-wracking
time but when you get the call like all
those nerves go away it's my why are we
here and it is true it's not it's not
real until it's real like the reports
yesterday we're saying the Knicks worked
out Kobe white yeah so everyone's like
alright hold on a minute we think RJ is
going could they switch it to Kobe when
do you think teams really know do you
really think it's when they're on the
clock that they really make that final
decision or you do you kind of have an
idea you got an idea yeah I think I do
like a day a day before I thought yeah
this our guy but they also know like if
someone has picked in front of them you
know and somebody drops as okay well if
we can grab him we'll take them but I
think for majority they have a clear set
like there's our number one but there's
our plan B Plan C yeah like say New York
say for example say like New Orleans say
we wanted to try to team up RJ Barrett
in Zion together and like we try and we
made a an offer to deal with that I we
got we got to take this offer then I say
okay you know we what
our guy was gonna be RJ Barrett but now
we now we don't have so I think you
always have to have that back up plan
like okay say we move down to spot we
can't get him but we still got this guy
so I think you always have to have that
like playing be you know just know who
you're gonna get but you need that Plan
B can you imagine that happen of any of
the Duke guys in Atlanta
yes still possible I think I got I think
I got us pick in cam yeah you're doing
pretty well thanks man
I got that right I got that I actually
do know I think I did get that but the
Timberwolves selected Jarrett over
mm-hmm did you have that I think I did
I think I had him up on the pink before
to clean Freeman that's why I think I
anima but he's like one of my sleepers
in the trash you know what he did in a
tournament and how he played you know
he's got he's got the size he's got the
skill he can he can handle it pull off
the bounce explosive he can go he can
play so Tim was picked up a good one
right here and he showed everybody like
on a big stage what he can do a man
named for himself so you know he ain't
just gonna continue to get better he
said each and every year in a league so
I like this pitch well I know one of the
critiques
Jericho BER was that he's not the best
ball handler do you see that at all when
you watch him I thought honestly I
thought you know in the tournament
watching him then he was he was bringing
that ball up putting players in
positions and getting getting downhill
so I thought he was he was solid with
this ball handling so me it you know as
I said we're evaluating kha'zix coming
in to be a rookie yeah it's gonna get
different type of training that's gonna
be playing against pros every single day
so they're gonna continue to get better
what do you think of Jericho I like him
I'm kind of touch with you know with
Tobias that he's someone I think who's
doesn't get enough credit
I'll see you know you had a lot of no
big names in the draft I think somewhere
he cut his name kind of fell
no fell out the mix a little bit but I
think he's someone who got to be very
good you know ball handle is always
something you can teach and and and
that's something that you can always
work on and but like I said I don't
think he's a tip he can still handle a
rock it's not like he takes two dribbles
and and fumbling the ball all over the
place so and he's not you know he's not
gonna be a point guard for you know for
them so you know he doesn't have to
bring the ball up take ten dribbles try
to change or he doesn't have to do all
that so I think that's something that's
I think people with a lot of people look
for your weaknesses and the especially
in the end these picks you don't talk as
much about your starting they try to
find weaknesses and I think this I think
that'd be good
speaking of strengths Josh claims to be
perfect right now it's all about the six
I had dairy okay you had an advantage
riots don't let it get you dead okay
don't let it get visitors case his
advantage can cuz he knew about the
trays that happen Bleacher Report for
cuz when they made a trade y'all should
have been able to you know make it Lord
you know I wait I waited to yeah so on
okay you know Drive days always crazy so
you know how to be how to be ready you
know anyway seventh pick is in the Bulls
select Kobe white yeah I think I heard
that I hope is North Carolina's very own
you had that too I think I might have a
cochlear to look at you know in the
studio house 2020 yeah well we white so
I okay this is my pick most competitive
player in this whole draft well he he
out there to get it every single night
and think about him that I like is that
everybody looks at him is like
six-two what not but he measured at 65
so he's taller there what a lot of
people think so so six five not the hair
yes see that's another thing yeah see I
think it might be the hair I've seen him
in person I don't think he's five but I
like his I like his uh his skill package
his speed and how he just plays the game
at a high level Sheldon I think it's a
good pick for a boss yeah John Moran and
garland in the sense of he's can't they
don't Chicago to that appointment right
now
you know they got they got Chris Dunn
around you know so that I have to too
soft but he you know he's someone do I
think they're kind of gives you key pair
of him is that Glavine I have a really
good backcourt and I mean he's changed
gears well playmates Tobias talked about
his competitive competitive nature and I
think in the league I think that that's
one of the biggest thing is there's that
competitive nature I do wonder how much
was obviously you were coached by Jay
Wright one of the best coaches in
college basketball how much it helps
when you have such a good coach he
learned everything under Williams the
same thing they think about those Duke
guys they're learning over these really
really good pedigrees of coaches how
much did that help you in the league um
it helped a lot you know cuz coach where
I just really hope me understand the
game of basketball and how to play the
right way and there's how to be a good
man off the court and I think that's one
thing that's kind of overlooked is you
know off the court you know that off the
court activity really feeds into the
court you know he's on to the court so
coach Wright was you know monumental in
my growth as a player and as a person
and I think when you have someone like
that who helps you in both aspects on
and off the court I think you can always
find success you know no matter where
your picture no matter where year your
situation is the rumor earlier today was
just the trade rumors people talk about
and everything like that signing rumors
that what
was going to get an offer from the Bulls
did you guys read that malcolm brogdon
oh he's gonna get off that was the real
name okay America still be true yeah I
guess future but it just isn't true yet
so I have to say it's a rumor so that
everyone knows that it has not happened
what would you think of that if he came
to Chicago
I mean Malcolm's a good player
I think Chicago's in a runner for a
couple good players patrick beverley
hometown kid West Side Chicago so you
know you you bringing in the tough
gritty title player knows how to play
sacrifice for the team so he's a free
agent too so they're gonna have options
to look at the guard position
you know they got Otto Porter in a trade
to who's a good three and D type player
so they got good pieces around them and
Zach Lavine obviously to to compliment
those type of guys do you do you ever
think this is just a weird question has
that to do with anything with Kobe white
sometimes when people have longer hair
they seem slower than they are like on
the court when you watch him because of
the hair I think that but some people
say that about players that wear black
socks really the black socks make you
look slower
yeah like coming out a college they was
like yo don't be one of no black socks
there's like a whole school thing though
don't like your coaches used to be like
to me like when I was in walking don't
be precious much sauce why I was like
because they got the Steinway say
players with a black sighs it makes them
look slow so that's interesting I could
kind of see that more than but when I
see the hair just you just kind of look
so what are some other weird what else
does your coach tell you that's just
that's just a few okay I know we have a
look of how you would look with Kobe
White's hair Oh
[Music]
you look slow I don't know I'm not mad
at it
no that's a bad picture first that was
like two or three years ago I don't even
know they'll be to my junior or senior
year at the combine that looks terrible
yeah it fits of eyes a bit more it's the
hairline oh good Photoshop by the way
hey the best photoshopping ever you guys
though do you feel like you have a
signature thing about Kobe has his hair
what's yours hmm maybe my head bent I
guess like people be like recognize me
for the headband I guess so
[Music]
it's okay you don't need it you don't
need to trademark because you have Zion
Williams in and we have reaction from
fans at Berkeley it's about getting Zion
Williams
Neuer baby it's a where baby yes sir
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a new era baby
taeyeon season you know sire we're in
the building they say the racial salad
Joss heart be ready
Lonzo be ready I think I'll still take
babies oh that's called I will say this
device part of a good point how many new
pelicans fans do we have now
too many No I made a good but they got
all all your fans they got all big
baller brand fans but over all brand in
France
desire he you know he like a fan
favorite for kids now so y'all got
definitely a lot of fans I'm sure he
doesn't got a lot new North Carolina I
think it depends on just let this next
pick if we get if we get a I think my
mark I think I had us taking came Redis
so if we take him that means we have
them too and brand new guys yeah Piazza
do guy so I think we'll have a that's
the thing like you got whether you have
camera not y'all have a squat now we got
a nice little mob it's gonna be it's fun
it'd be it'd be good and then we got you
know our vet I guess I've ever and that
would be drew you know who is I think is
a very underrated player who's for sure
offensively and really good defensively
so I think we got a good young core
young nucleus to really build a winning
culture around I know we have a visual
of what you guys are gonna look like
when you take the court can we pull that
up just so you know we can let Josh
really feel it be a little more
visualize it nice little mob I hope
a small Ball lineup
no okay I gotta fight put jaw in there
to have MVR Center maybe I might draft
the center with this bit all right
you know just outside you know you you
got Brandon Ingram you got Lonzo
do you miss Kyle yeah you know that's my
guy obviously you know this there's
leagues of business so any but it is by
God you know to my to my boys with me
and you know we ready to go eat some
beignets and have have fun Hoover yeah
but you seem like you guys are like
actually really good friends yeah we
were
yeah and still are you know it's a
little different now you know when I see
them on two core batata I don't know if
I can I see cool on the Kuomintang buses
ass but you know off the cording that's
my man that's my brother you know after
that we have a glass of wine and you
know call it a day I do have one of my
favorite Josh Hart Kyle Kuzma moments
something let's roll it
I'm Mayo guy oh my god hey man this is
some boy make some money in my life
all right well swap oisin there we go
walk over towards him what's a good
player what's gonna play good man it's
telling you this mother Mayo all day I'm
gonna smelling mayonnaise all day giulio
go grab his bread and get the mayonnaise
off his face and just wipe it off yeah
yeah yeah go back to the guy go back
just gotta make sure everything's good
you get a man need anything in
particular you looking for oh I've been
looking for that my man thank you
mmm
oh my god oh I got a little bit left
hold up you got mayonnaise and now they
ran out yes that's a friend you want so
that's a friend you're good
see this is shout out shout out to Kyle
Oh - Kyle OH - you guys doing pranks
eighth pick is in oh my god
Jackson Hays thanks this why did you
pick him there okay so I picked him
because he's like the typical type big
man now hold on Tom we can bring up the
maghreb he had kickball a grand it was
inland weapons Atlanta you had camera
eight but all right now that new
toothpick you did right before you did
center because okay this we all said
Kansas why he could block shots he can
run the floor y'all were lacking in the
center position a little bit so that's
why I said it but you know he's he's
still got a little bit ways to go but he
can he can run and jump in if you can do
that in the NBA and stay healthy and his
size he's gonna be a good player I got a
rebound low ball on the average like
five rebounds but once he starts doing
that he'll be great teammate ya know I
think it's a good pick especially with
ya I think it's really good for us
because we have with him and Ja jahlil
okafor I think we have it a good kind of
change of pace yeah you have him who
would be I think he could be an elite
roller shot blocker
defender you know law guy and then on
the other side you have job who's
obviously definitely improved on his
defensive end but I think you know you
probably talked to him playing a little
more but like them down down in the
block I think he's I want I don't want
to say automatic I don't want to jinx it
like them I think he's very good on the
block so I think with those two
different styles
it could really you know help us play
either no either either way well he is
ranked as the second most efficient
scorer in college basketball with a 75%
true shooting percentage yeah so that
should make you feel good expecially
where's Owen there's only drew
definitely be able to create play make
form by the way that ain't that hard to
do are you doing this that's true but
hey we got we got two guys that can
definitely affect with Drew playing with
a edu it was kind of that same that same
style so obviously ATS a great player in
this league and I think this guy's is
somewhat similar to him so I think he
can definitely learn from Drew and learn
from zone just cuz they've been in that
situation now the pelicans are kind of
stealing draft night I mean they
certainly are your team is doing very
very well but when you look at it what
is the thing you think you're missing
what can you guys get now we know
worried about done I mean what I say we
already it's funny about how it's good
it's rated the right ad but that turned
into bi so myself
Jackson Hays the 17th pick in this
drives at 35th picking this draft to
first rounders from LA I think a first
rounder from Cleveland the right to swap
with LA for 23 and 25 new picks in those
years so we got a lot of it was it was a
tweet today I see oh
today all right before I go I'm like wow
that's a lot you know David yeah yeah
Grif did a great job of you know he
can't you know he out the legal a [ __ ]
came back there's some heavy yeah I'm
happy he luckily he fell into to enter
our boat and I think we you know got a
young cross the ad is a great player but
I think we got a nice little young mob I
think we can compete you know even what
was it's like the most athletic
frontcourt in the NBA Astra I mean and
if you are saying Zion is the most
athletic athletic all right that nine
figures in the wizard select Bowie Hachi
Mira
I don't Gonzaga it's a good pick for us
yeah and I think it's random apply see
is the first ever Japanese players which
is amazing shout out to him for that
what if you guys seen out of ruie so I
like coming into the the season I guess
and the tournament they you know his
stock went up game by game but he's
physical he can score you know plays
majority for position but also may
develop into a little bit more of a
three but you know he has a size and the
physicality to to to play against the
bigger guys so I like his skill seconds
you can shoot the ball he can block
shots he can run I think it's a good
pick for Wizards you guys he could give
you the SWAT him in at the three four
spot and let it let him live work out
there we're Bradley Beal it and John
Wall when he gets healthy so I like this
pick for them this is a guy that was
like a top five picking some direct mock
drafts in the middle of season so it's a
good pick mm-hmm yeah night letting a
Zygon dunks first-team all-american a
fourth ever NBA player from Japan first
drafted which is monumental so congrats
tuned for that as I said do we think
it's strange camreta still on the board
optimist I think he's yeah he's one of
the guys has elite up side I think he
can be an all-star he's definitely the
smoothest I think the smoothest guy in
the draft
I'm just goes there wise so I am kind of
surprised to see that he's still on them
but I mean guys might have issues with
in you know the need that kept him out
for a little bit but you never know and
obviously it's all depending on fit and
style exactly and this is another like
how we talked about when it was our turn
to be drafted we looking at other teams
that we work out for so if he kind of
went into this process of look I'm a top
five pick only worked out for a couple
of teams there's some other things that
get to see him up close in front and
that could affect some some players
draft stock too so you know I could play
into it but a lot of these picks have
been based off of it and what teams want
so I mean I had him I forgot what pic I
had a matter but yeah I'm a pic so let
me he's kind of slipping right now so
we'll see what happens mm-hmm all right
you guys it looks like the 10th pick is
in and um you might have spoken into
existence it is camera other way around
I thought we were gonna pick cam I
thought they were gonna pick Jackson
Hayes okay yeah but I think cam can't be
really good for him he can go in not
have it to hurt her like it's one of the
wings Bazemore Torian princess you know
just got traded I think you know he's
able to step in take some of those
menacing and some of that role and I
think he'd be a very good player you
know there's obviously just continue to
grow and to get better but I mean he's
he's a great shooter which I think the
Hawks need every NBA team at this point
needs a great shooter but the Hawks I
really need it what do you like out of
camp to us this smooth player you know
you got the full full arsenal way we can
beat you off the bounce you can shoot
the pull-up jumper make the threes
I think that motormate one of many
reasons why he may have slip a little
bit just some people got a question his
motor mm-hmm but when you put it on a
team like your team then Atlanta Hawks
and you running up and down your motors
gonna be pushed with that young talent
so yeah he's gonna be able to find
himself there
all right a lot of stuff happening with
the draft which means a lot of stuff is
changing in Vegas let's go out to Sin
City and talk to Kelly thanks Taylor I'm
gonna give you guys a special treat
today we're gonna go behind the scenes
of the B are betting stage super awesome
the door is not opening but we're going
to get it here shortly give you guys a
nice treat we're going to talk to one of
the oddsmakers here in Las Vegas the guy
who sets the lines crunches all the
numbers to give you guys some of the
best value that there is
fantastic Kelly all right you guys it is
right now pick 11 and I would like some
wine if we have any it's about that time
he's the white mount yeah come on good
morning come on in you're out
I need a glass I also haven't had a
beignet yet oh you oh you to do again
but close your laptop
yeah it's gonna get everywhere it's
going to actually get everywhere
wait you were talking about all the
different wines you like no the gloves
oh we have the founder of house of a
highlight do you have a chair I don't
think so or I could just sit right on
the floor what do we have over here can
I have a glass
I saw him drink wounds I'm good selected
yes speaking of Zion Omar in house of
highlights you guys were the first
people to ever post as ion highlight
yeah like when he was 16 years old
yeah like December of like 2015 he was
like 16 years old we get sent the clip
there you go I finally got a chair
mm-hmm and what was interesting then is
once we sent in one clip his entire high
school would just send him clips over
and over and over and over again but
what ends up happening is we to get
posted a lot everyone starts talking
trash so every time someone would say he
can't shoot he's just a dunker he's
Shannon Brown 2.0 so it was cool for me
to like see that he became the kid that
a lot of people hated on in high school
and then he went to college and now he's
better be a first overall pick even
though every single time it felt like he
got his props people ended up hating on
him yeah yeah and now whenever you guys
post he was like where's his eye on
stuff lately taken home but the thing
that's really interesting about Zion as
well he was a celebrity in college
before College now it's life is changing
yes
he's already been so high-profile he had
like a million followers before he hit
Duke I think yeah I mean now he has what
3 4 5 million he's yeah when Drake
where's your Jersey mm-hmm when you're
16 years old I think that's when you
know you've kind of made it yeah so it's
it's really cool to see kind of his
evolution because you could easily get
lost in that at 16 15 years old and he
never has shown any signs of losing it
by the way how do you feel about Drake
superfan am I Xander City we can serve
Isis base how do you feel about drink no
I think you know he's he's good [ __ ]
yeah I mean so he reps us see hard you
know that's that's him so congrats to
them but man you know he he represent
mad at him he's relevant to all around
yeah but when you guys see us posting
Drake over and over and over again do
you feel away about it yeah hopping is a
if you the other team and you don't like
it yeah you might you gotta do you gotta
do you suppose they're on the course so
entire that's my thing did you guys ever
play the rafters in Toronto when he was
courtside nope y'all did yeah you do you
notice it when he's over there yeah yeah
he does his talking yeah did he say
anything specifically to you know it was
like cuz we finished game five and we
lost and I was like we'll be back for
Game seven he was like he was just like
no you know you won't know and he did so
he's on the court he's like you know
he's where the coaching is supposed to
be he's yeah like right there so dang
yeah and the play at playoff Drake was a
different level talk yeah I was going
crazy 11th pick is in the Sun is select
Cameron Johnson UNC does any did anybody
have that oh the shooter I don't have it
damn Norton Wow
hey want to transfer some say to him I
don't have it all I I don't think is
that's a surprise okay where do you make
people have him not to go later he was
like definitely later in 26 I think yeah
he was like a least 26 late first like
so that may see whether two that work
out and killed it
yeah mm-hmm he probably a miss mm-hmm so
I mean and you know they're just traded
TJ war mm-hmm today so they're worse
with this shooting yeah for sure
I'm not surprised yeah hey how much do
those workouts matter like everything
knows everything out so you Donovan got
Donovan Mitchell God you're after the
bomb based on all work out cuz he bust
my ass I am ear down a really close and
I was and this was like my six work out
and it was he was fresh it was his first
one and while I tell you you know how
like you go against someone you see him
in college so you think like oh I'm a
plane this type of way so Donovan was
athletic finish at the room but couldn't
really you know didn't really showed he
could shoot in college I'm gonna sag off
a little bit he don't got no jump shot
I'm gonna lock him up he bust my ass got
a draft all I got working so Don I know
we might I might cut you tonight bro cuz
I know you gonna be in a city you're
welcome
thing is all you tonight drafted on that
workout man after your workout did you
feel it uh feel what like you were like
they like me
this went perfectly yeah I mean so there
was a few I was at that I was like man
got my best workout and then driving I
came and they drive somebody that I went
against and I was like yo thank yo this
was like matter of fact when I went to
Washington I had a great workout first
like auto forwards and then driving I
came they pick Chris Sale to another
thing I have really good work out there
you know I mean there was a couple of
them workouts don't know but my draft
class was good like yeah
place I always in workouts with the
Morris twins Kawhi Leonard Chandler
Parsons you know Chris Minnesota it was
like there was some really good workouts
of guys who who are now really good NBA
players so yeah it was cool
well I know we have a highlight
aficionado here and so it's only right
that I bring up a highlight that
actually has to do with you guys I would
like to get your take on this okay a
game you guys play it against each other
do we uh we have that ready oh I know
this high scores look at your feet trip
to the rough yeah well really mad about
was I think we can't I think we came
back a little bit and then they they got
then they got on a run so yeah and then
we and I was heated so then just how
competitive and you know I started
getting mad and and nice little fun like
Parker's got a little lighter that's the
thing when I was watching it I was
watching it though the foul
didn't look egregious thank you Oh Oscar
for that one yeah I deserved an Oscar
what they crazy no yellow one but hey
I'm trying to sell it the ref called my
bluff
and so is this the first time you guys
have like actually talks and said I know
you're not mad at each other but is it
the first time you're communicating
kobold buzzin like there's only so many
time we bash up because you guys let's
go on back to Vegas and check in with
Kelly thanks Taylor we got the door open
now it's time to head behind the scenes
we're gonna check in with one of my
favorite odds makers here at the Caesars
sports book we're gonna talk NBA 2019
2020 season see who he likes what the
straps is doing for the sports books
let's see who's behind door number one
and it's Matt alright Matt and Matt is
the manager of training here at seater
sports where he crunches all the numbers
puts in all the hard work so really that
I don't have to do that alright Matt
first question for you when you guys are
deciding on making these odds you guys
set these lines put the numbers out how
did you guys have the Lakers as a
favorite before the ad trade well when
you open futures up this early you
really have to do some speculation there
are a lot of people speculating on the
other side so you have to try to figure
out where they're gonna bet we open the
Lakers 20 to 1 they hammered 20 to 1
hammered 15 to 1 all the way down to I
think 5 to 1 and then the next day klay
Thompson and Katie got hurt so we had to
concede a little bit went ahead and bump
the Warriors up and then drop the Lakers
down alright so always interesting how
does that affect when the draft glasses
come out so we know Zions go into the
pelicans how does that affect the
pelicans odds well you know it's it's
really tough with the rookies you know
they're not quite worth as much as some
of these superstars some of those guys
you know ad KD LeBron might be worth 10
to 15 wins a guy like Zion coming in in
the first year he's just not going to be
worth that much so I would say the
average top 5 top 10 pick is probably
worth three to four wins I think what
Zions potentially could be worth up to
five or six so maybe the pelicans fans
should not get too excited alright we're
talking 2019 2020 title odds we just
mentioned the Lakers are currently the
favorite this year's champion the
Raptors send it 8 to 1 the Warriors at
11 to 1 most importantly where is the
money coming in we are seeing all Lakers
money right now it is crazy we've taken
five
more on the Lakers than any other team
so it's it's really all Lakers right now
we're really hoping they don't sign
another free agent we're really gonna be
in a tough spot
Oh bookmakers gonna be cheering against
the Lakers right along with me all right
Taylor Caesars Palace currently has your
Atlanta Hawks at a hundred to one are
you gonna make that bet
listen I'm loyal I believe in my team
I'm gonna make it it might not happen
but I'm not kind of bet against them
odds coming in he's gonna take your
wager Taylor thank you so much Kelly
all right before you guys are in them B
I know I talked about the Hawks a lot
who was your team Oh Lakers or Wizards
yeah Lakers cause of Kobe Wizards cars
downtown but I love d-wade I grew up a
big Kobe and Shaq fan so that was like
that at that time for me well that's why
I was like really loving basketball so I
used to watch them play a whole lot so
that was like my team back in the day
any of course we're Miami Heat yeah huge
Miami you fan yeah you're a Hawks fan
Hawks fan light what does that even mean
it means I'm from there so I root for
them but the only team I like died for
the Falcons but I root for the Hawks
trace is the beginning I'm not I'm not
gonna do that but I would root for the
Hawks if I had to pick a team does that
make sense but do you not have a rooting
interest like gladness season MBA no I
have I doesn't matter to me
so what games you like one or watch but
a lot of it is because you have to watch
the game so objectively I just don't
have a team that I'm wanting to win cuz
I just want a good game yeah I don't
really really keep that same energy if
the Hawks go to champion hey me the
pelicans that kind of yeah so mm like 22
23 ha you know pelicans Hawks and in the
finals but seriously when with this team
you
right now in New Orleans linkage I'll
make it to the fun to the playoffs into
the finals
this question finals playoffs finals
give us a couple years obviously I'm the
most I'm real I try to be realistic and
logical obviously I got I'm biased but I
think give us you know three four years
I think we gotta have time for you know
a lot of our young guys they're really
mature and really learned about the
league and hopefully in that time we can
get a know a couple of solid free agents
I think if we do that and you know we
have Graf who's who's been who created a
championship team and and we had luckily
we have him now so I think we can do
that and three or four years but I mean
there's there's a lot of ifs well you
know between now and then but I think if
we do what we're supposed to do and
handle the business I was supposed to
handle it and get better I think we can
be in the finals in three four years and
you know hopefully bring achieved in the
wall okay you guys might make the
playoffs this year though right yeah
talent yeah no don't go where we have
the talent you know but like I said I
talked about Lots going as as realistic
as possible I think we we can but I
think we have to definitely be quick
learners and like I said a lot of us are
young I think is I don't think it's out
of the the park I think we can
definitely make it I think we will make
it but we just got to make sure we are
quick learners and just continue that
junk our dog mentality that I think all
of us really have 12th pick is in the
Hornet select PJ Washington at a
competitor teen
yeah someone he would take why did you
like at a PJ why did you want only like
them cuz I met him when he was a high
school prospect and he was like a really
top five top ten high school prospect
and he just had all the town in the
world so like I was just hoping that
since I met him before yeah that's kind
of who do why do you guys like PJ
Washington well he went to Kentucky so
yeah I know oh he's rock nation
rock boy
I got to see him play a lot this year
cuz they played against Tennessee and he
always was that one play that was was
going to work and I said man he didn't
slow down but he's got size athleticism
can play on on the low block which is
like in today's game now at the four
position
you know you a lot of players kind of
like that so he can play actually like
four or five different lineups he can
run the floor he's young too so I mean
he's got a lot of skill and ability and
on Charlotte a team that has a different
different parts of different pieces but
I figure out what they're doing all
season this is a good fit for him and a
good team huh have you met him being a
fellow I met him once good kid crooked
obviously you know like I you know said
that he's a good kid he's a Greg and and
you know the guys you really Ruth when
you guys want to be successful I'm out
of where where they are no matter where
what team you're on you want guys like
that to be successful okay so the
Hornets now have mr. nice guy PJ
Washington
what's our kimba prediction i thought
you can't say I don't know yeah you
gotta keep Kimble yeah like he's there's
not too many players and I laid mouth
that play with the same team like his
man put everything on from shop for
Charlotte right like from day one into
now like he'd been on TV want to stay
there so he eligible for a Super Max too
so it's got to be a common ground where
you figure it out and you gotta reward
him because he's been loyal to you not
once as he came out said yeah I want to
trade something like that
he led team to the playoffs couple years
back they almost made playoffs this year
so you got to build pieces around him
and be okay with that but my sleeper of
the draft has not been picky and I'm
kind of disappointed
you already said you had a sleeper sleep
that siku - oh he's out of friends yeah
is gonna steal how many sleepers have
you had the big sleep deep sleep this is
my like you know like when a bear it
goes to hibernate like yeah I had him at
nine nine what do you like about him
though
okay one thing was when he was playing
over it in France but she said he's
playing over France he's playing against
professional players all right yeah and
he was playing playing well shoot the
three boys athletic he's six nine and a
half okay mom
can push the rock I like him and like
he's more experienced than a lot of
these guys playing in college so I like
that aspect of them too that he's coming
a little bit more polished so I'm
surprised he's been dropping so far I
thought a team like Charlotte that would
have been a good picker friend but who
knows maybe he'll get drafted soon all
right say kudumbam we could see there's
still time to exist he's next we still
have a couple more picks left on the DR
2019 NBA draft show let's take a look at
the guys that have already gone
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the paint bared and covered the shame
with a dream we would have fortune and
fame Amanda baked come in the abate to
frame babe
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I have to say something really
understand just happen here Josh Hart
was talking about the pelicans and if
they talk to him
what did repeat what you just said have
to give the person the opportunity he
didn't take it so okay that's what it is
and I already put you on the spot with
the smiling like you got a bond I could
we do have a comment though somebody
named Sarah was talking about who you
guys were saying about Kimba she says
Kimber's gonna score 50 points per game
next year which is outrageous but I say
but I do agree that next year we will
see Kimba have probably his best year of
his career yeah 50 points is someone
named Dre said they're sleeping on bull
bull actually forgot about Bobo and his
fighters who we haven't seen him yet
Kyra is talking about you and Donovan
Mitchell says Donovan Mitchell should
have went higher I had him as the first
pick I guess he didn't bust your ass
hard nothin Utah was my yet if anyone
finds out about this workout they're
done yeah and I'll tell you
and actually speaking of Bulbul I saw
the Donovan was not a big fan of him
wearing the spider oh he made a joke on
Twitter nice guy yeah he was joking on
Twitter like um excuse me how often I
guys think about like if they redid my
draft I would have gotten picked here
did you ever do that cuz you guys both
would have been picked way higher or way
earlier mm-hm
how about would've been tough 15 yeah I
mean I don't know if you love nothing
really matter yeah you know that's not
what happened it's just it's just
someone behind the computer saying oh I
think this and that's it's like their
own personal opinion so that's not how
it happens you know we take the the cars
that were given and we make the best of
it your teammate there pick who they
make it a sleeper Tyler Harrell from
Kentucky I don't know who that is
I hope he's really good where's the
camera I hope he's really good I don't
know who you are but I hope you make
threes because okay no he's a he's a
nice with the ball okay
tall tall for good for a two guard in
league with Kentucky last year surprised
a lot of people just with his ability to
go off the bounce a little bit and
create great shots for himself but it's
a good place our players good IQ for the
game knows how to play can play off the
ball on the ball so it's a solid pick up
buddy he he's no doing weight though
that's gonna be tough going in when do
you think y'all will be back no I think
I say it all the time like we had our
moment with LeBron and that was gonna be
the best ten years of my life watching
basketball so I don't know if it'll ever
happen again
I think another ten years like where
it'll it's gonna just take forever to we
have a lot of bad contracts they just
need to take some time get some better
draft picks because we traded all of
them for like Goran Dragic and even when
we did a sign-in tray for LeBron back in
the
so we need pics we need cap space to
make it happen okay now speaking of when
is a team gonna be back I guess our Jay
Baer had a message to New York and
Knicks fans what said I'm here I love
you let's try to get back to that
championship way
what's wrong with the Knicks we can all
just zoom in on Josh's face this is his
response to a my to our day's message
also it's advice oh what's wrong with
the Knicks and when will they get back
and when I start with you Josh I don't
want to say with I want to say there's
something wrong with oh I just got a
young fella you know people in New York
I think New York City a tough place I
think I think Philly's tougher cuz
Philly if they when they love you they
love you just with me being being there
for you they love you they love you but
if you ain't doing good they definitely
gonna let you know I think New York is a
little bit like that I think I got you
know Kevin Knox who's gonna is good dsj
it'll be it was a solid point guard but
if you got him mr. Robinson it'll be
good so they got some a couple good
young pieces but they gotta definitely
make some some noise you know free
agency so I mean we'll see what happens
hey you never know maybe KD you never
know maybe I don't know what do you
think for agency I don't know I can't
tell you he devoured his beignet I
wasn't giving a sign
oh the 14th pick is in the Celtics
select Romeo Langford Oh Big Ten
basketball represent I can't talk I
don't think we had any nice guys what do
you like about Romeo yeah it's a good
pick I mean obviously like I think it's
not kind of drought because his team
didn't really do what they needed to do
this year but really good player could
play either one too
in my opinion more more on the two guard
side but he can create his own shot he
can score he can get down here and he's
explosive I've got athletics athleticism
so he can play I was surprised I don't
think I had him in my mock because of
the fits of team but I think this is a
different for him to come in and just
grow us play I think cam Johnson kind of
messed up a lot of mocs yeah anybody saw
him really rising like yeah but what's
interesting now obviously we're seeing
some major names falling out of the
lottery say guten boya people thought
was going to be lottery Bulbul another
North Carolina guy and I see a little
yeah so what which of those name
surprises you the most probably was sake
sake who say kuden boy I probably say
him I know
bobble I'll see no you have questions
with you know his strengths and you know
position he could play I was he's very
skilled but just know where he could
really fit in there nice very little I
think it might be a little undersized I
think the biggest one is probably sacred
cool Thank You room boy yeah yeah I
agree with that too and I was saying a
little bit on Nazir little too I mean he
didn't have the best college career why
who was there but I thought that sake
who just got drafted by the Pistons as a
good place your sleeper
I know I okay a lot happened in the
lottery let's recap all the dreams that
came true and all the additions to
rosser's across the NBA Xion one jaw -
RJ Barrett okay you know what I'm really
amazed I'm getting really upset because
I know Josh won the mock one for DeAndre
hunter five Darius garland six Jarrett
Colver seven Kobe why I think that's
gonna be really exciting Kobe white on
the pools Jackson Hayes New Orleans Rui
gotcha Mira - the Wizards cab reddish -
the Hawks Cameron Johnson on the Suns PJ
Washington Hornets Tyler hair out - the
heat that heat and Romeo Langford - the
Celtics lottery
that was fun I do have one question for
each of you before we sign off mm-hmm
you are a free agent I want you to tell
us all what's the most important thing
to you for your next team most important
thing for me is I would say stop play
that's the most important thing for me
is you know that's big with myself in my
game of how I envision myself playing
and vision myself growing and getting
better a year year after year so style
play for my type of game is the number
one thing that I'm looking for in free
agency okay and the side of the play
that you prefer is can you elaborate on
that okay yeah up and down
[Laughter]
you know kind of like that where
everybody pitches the modern-day NBA
team to beat listen let's shoot threes
get down hill let's get to the
free-throw line because those are the
most efficient ways but ball movement is
biggest thing so that stop that style
play is most fitting for me okay
there we go yeah now for you Josh
obvious
you've had a crazy you know we things
have changed for you went from the
Lakers to the pelicans so now you have a
good idea of two different teams in the
NBA what would you tell a player who was
going to play for the Lakers what do
they need to know about the franchise
yeah you got the best player in the
league on your team now you got another
you know a couple of good guys there so
just get better being a moment and have
fun I mean just for what it's worth you
deaf you told us things we already know
mm-hmm we know that you guys have the
best player yeah I need to know what is
your advice Laker that you think would
help them within that franchise
I'd say we're being in that market being
under as much scrutiny as you are don't
get too high don't get too low you know
cuz when I you know I that I've been
there you know at low points and when
you're at your low points they'll bury
you and even one get but if your high
points are praise you so don't get too
hard don't get too low it's a great
opportunity but it comes with a lot of I
don't want to say burdened but you know
just with this the I don't want to say
pressure I don't really care about the
pressure but just a pressure for some
guys and the you know the spotlights
that's not always you know doesn't
always work out for some people so I
think that's probably what I would say
um but I was getting into too much
detail into what he was smiling and it's
Instagram story that's just the mystery
for us forever yeah do we accept that
answer too I suppose good okay
to lastly talk to those that just got
drafted what would you say to them about
this life-changing night I always say
enjoy for one you hit the lotto yeah
enjoy the moment enjoy it but understand
there's a lot that comes with it so be
ready for everything that's about to
come your way and don't be afraid to say
no because you know a lot of pressure is
coming towards you you gotta be your own
man in this league on and off the floor
so just be ready for that anything to
add um I probably said and kind of don't
be a don't be afraid to say no but also
don't be afraid to ask for help
the biggest thing I think a lot of guys
it feels like okay they're kind of on
their own for the first time they gotta
do it by themselves
but you know that's why you got great
vets I don't know what to buy is going
to be you have Tobias on your team he's
a he's a great bet I'm gonna model
yourself I have to after on and off the
court so don't be afraid to say no and
I'll take a drink it is Jordan Kevin
yeah wait we're the only ones drinking
so we got it she is gonna give me a
little more get a little more end of the
lottery Jordan K know you'll have some
water yes
bring the water don't get it on my
laptop Norton beignets because I'm eat
those all right to be our 2019 draft
you guys are fantastic two devices free
agency to new destinations the house of
highlights to all of you watching out
there thanks for joining us we're hungry
we're gonna eat have a good rest of the
dress
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]